und wir begrüssen jetzt in
meinungsforscher herrn binkert guten
morgen herr berger hat wie sehen sie das
waren sie überrascht von den
entwicklungen gestern niemand für
wahrscheinlich gehalten dass es so
ausgeht ja schon überrascht das nicht
erwarten
etwas was ist das wahrscheinlichste
szenario wenn es neuwahlen geben dann
würde die fdp vermutlich aus dem landtag
aus fliegen oder abgestraft werden dafür
ja ich bin ja kein prophet sein
meinungsforscher und die stimmung in
thüringen ist immer eine stimmung wie
ergebnisse eng ausgehen und ich
bezweifle ist man bei neuwahlen groß
anderes ergebnis hätte ich meine das
besondere an japaner die thüringen war
ja dass die ränder das linke und da ich
gehe zusammen stärker sind als alle
anderen parteien zusammen und das alle
da verteidigen mitmachen muss damit es
eine mehrheit gibt also ohne die linke
oder ohne zustimmung afb kann überhaupt
keine mehrheit gebildet werden
ja und das ist natürlich eine
entwicklung die wir auch im bund
zunehmend sehen und deshalb ist thüring
so relevant oder der fall so relevant
für den bund oder in thüringen ist halt
schon diese sondersituation das linke
und ein free zusammen mehrheit haben
diese situation hat man sonst nirgends
in deutschland wie die sich abzeichnet
dass man mit einem einer partei vom rand
kooperieren muss und überhaupt wir halt
noch bilden zu können
genau genau also diese sache dass über
50 prozent der mandate von lincoln afw
gesetzt werden
es gibt nirgendwo anders zu deutschland
und auch nicht im bundestag
wir wollen jetzt einmal unsere zuschauer
zu wort kommen lassen hier und hören mal
in die erste zuschauerfrage
ich frage mich ob es neue wand
seine frage nach neuwahlen konnten sie
die höheren herr becker die frage war
wird es neuwahlen geben
ja also ich habe ja schon gesagt das
ergebnis der neuwahlen wird
wahrscheinlich nicht groß anders sein
als jetzt die zusammensetzung ist und
der weg zu behalten ist ja nicht dazu
erfahren also man braucht ja erstmal
kommt eine frauen frage stellen wenn er
verliert und kein anderer gewählt wird
könnte es noch über einen geben oder ist
auch mit zwei-drittel-mehrheit im
landtag für neuwahlen
ja es könnte neuwagen gehen aber dann
müssten auch wirklich ja müsste es auch
bei deutlich mehr einen tag für diese
neuwahlen geben danke mir die nächste
frage mein name ist marco astrium und ja
ich finde es unverschämt und ich frage
mich was die fdp vor allen dingen der
lindner da gemacht hat ja das war ein
absolut falsches spiel
die frage ist jetzt wie gehen wir gehen
unsere politiker damit um und wie
wird der mann jetzt direkt zum rücktritt
gezwungen damit sich die wahl wiederholt
ja das war die frage wie gehen unsere
politiker damit um und wird er zum
rücktritt gezwungen es ist eben gar
nicht so einen haken minister recht
einfach zurückgeben weil das land muss
ja regiert mit untergehen regierungschef
da sein er kann ankündigen dass er
zurücktreten bilder werden uns praktisch
ist es ein nachfolger benannt sein als
er kann nicht einfach jetzt nach hause
fahren sagen also ich mach das nicht
selbst gewählt
er kann durch ein konstruktives
misstrauensvotum gestürzt werden wenn
ein anderer politiker im landtag findet
er kann die vertrauensfrage stellen kann
die vertrauensfrage verlieren und
dadurch können neuwahlen rauskommen aber
also es ist alles es gibt nicht diesen
ganz ganz einfachen weg zumindest die
zwei drittel mehrheit gäbe es ja aber
ohne die kfd also er müsste dann die
kommissarische sagen die regierung
kommissarisch weiterführen
ja ich weiß auch ganz wundersame welche
partei für oder gegen neuer ein sind ja
auch ein bisschen gleich davon ab welche
erwartungen man hat den blick auf den
ausgang einer möglichen ja das ist ja
das nächste thema sind die sind die
verhältnisse dann so viel klarer als sie
jetzt sind
wahrscheinlich haben viele dazu hohe
hoffnungen die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
eher dass das resultat ähnlich ist wie
jetzt oder so ist es also das war ja in
thüringen die sind diese blöcke relativ
stabil und ich wirklich nicht erwarten
wenn nur über allen lehrern das ist also
ein ganz anderes erlebnis werden
dann haben wir sprechen wir mit thomas
witter ein zuschauer der westlb
zugeschaltet ist herr witte ihre frage
einwohnerschwund kontakt ich würde erst
mal interessieren wie sie es sehen
unsere bundes politiker anderer parteien
die medien rufen jetzt auch das war
neuer mp von theorien zurücktritt
sie sorgen es war und demokratisch wirst
du prez ist aber mit ganzen klausuren
es war eine demokratische wahl finden
sie es nicht auch und demokratisch wie
sich aktuell zum fall thüringens alte
herr becker findet es undemokratisch die
reaktion war demokratisch logisch
weichen die regeln eingehalten worden
das ist und es ist letztlich in ein
spiegelbild des des ergebnisses der
landtagswahl man darf ja auch nicht
vergessen dass der ministerpräsident
ramelow der in der bevölkerung einen us
ansehen genießt immer gesagt hat ihr
könnt mich wählen mit drei parteien
linke spd grüne und diese drei verteilen
haben eben zusammengenommen im letzten
jahr im oktober weniger stimmen gehabt
als vor fünf jahren
und deshalb hat praktisch rot rot grün
bei der letzten landtagswahl die
mehrheit verloren
insofern war das ja von vornherein
bekannt dass es schwierig wird damit
nicht gerade im jahr handeln zu bekommen
ja also das ist er hätte sich vielleicht
noch mehr vorher blumen müssen wirklich
eine ausreichende mehrheit
zusammenbekommen er ist auch dieses
risiko eingegangen
in der hoffnung im dritten wahlgang das
zu schaffen das ist auch die frage ob
auch diese eine ihrer an den tag gelegt
hat so zwingend war er wird den kopf
geschüttelt
warum ist das augenwischerei die die
medien und die bundespolitik zurück
dafür dass immer mehr vertrauen
erschüttert wurde mit denen es gerade
abgeht macht ihrer parteien die die ofd
nur noch stärker aber begreift das nicht
die leute schütteln den kopf das gegen
demokratische wahlen vorgegangen wird
noch matteo kunz hat das ergebnis nicht
gepasst also tritt zurück
wir wählen das kann es doch nicht sein
dass so lange gewährt worden ist es
unsere politiker elite passt wer gerade
die erste nachricht hat ich finde es
eine absolute sauerei und hat mit
demokratie nicht das entfernteste zu tun
keine frage dass auch einfach die hand
und meine doch gar nicht komme ich mir
angucke sie haben darum geschummelt die
frage ist finden sie es gerechtfertigt
dass über die neuen führung gesorgt wird
es ist eine zäsur wo die demokratie hat
mit demokratie in wohlstand der
lächerlichkeit preisgegeben nein es war
eine demokratische wahl und das was
gabriel mahr ist gramm konto ziehen ja
und liest sich alle schimpfen über diese
weisung das ist und immer keusch und das
ist beschämend und da geht man doch gar
nicht überwiesen fraktionsvorsitz der
linken geäußert indem sie ein buch
streits gerufen hat das ist nicht
demokratisch
was danach gesagt wurde das sind
meinungsäußerungen das ist die
meinungsfreiheit die herrschaften wie
sie genannt haben genauso haben wie sie
ihre meinungsfreiheit haben aber hemmen
können sie nachvollziehen
diesen frust den er wird hier zum
ausdruck bringt dass er sagt da ist
jetzt jemand demokratisch gewählt kann
man argumentieren naja 5 prozent hat die
fdp bekommen jetzt stellt sie den
ministerpräsident 95 prozent der
thüringer haben ihn nicht gewählt und
trotzdem soll er sie jetzt regieren aber
dennoch das ist er wurde demokratisch
gewählt und soll jetzt zum rücktritt
sozusagen gezwungen werden
was heißt gezwungen also er ist
letztlich im amt und es liegt an ihm wie
er behandelt es kann jeder in auf ford
um zurückzutreten aber es kann niemanden
zu zwingen
insofern ist das schon klar aber die
empörung ist ein sehr sehr groß ja aber
man kann den leuten auch nicht verbieten
empört zu sein also ich denke das ist
eine sache
manche werden sich freuen manche werfen
sich ärgern so ist das aber ich kann
bieten seine meinung zu sagen ist eine
kritische oder seine zustimmen ich
glaube das gehört einfach das gehört
dazu dass in der parlamentarischen
demokratie nicht zwangsläufig derjenige
gewählt wird der die stärkste kraft
stellt
das camp als auch bodo ramelow ist 2017
auch ministerpräsident geworden obwohl
seine linke parteien nur zweitstärkste
kraft genannt wird
danke sehr danke herr witte wir gehören
einmal den nächsten zuschauer
ich bin mir während ringier 24 jahre alt
und ich frage mich ist es überhaupt
legal ein fdp mann mit auf die stimmen
zu wählen
ob legal ist sehr ähnliche frage haben
wir glaube ich bereits etabliert
gewissen verpflichtet und können haben
das freie mandat b zu beenden ist das
amt am geeignetsten halten und natürlich
ist das legal haben kemmerich zu sehen
warum wird ein fdp fdp mann von der afg
mit gewählt das kann gar nicht sein das
kann gar nicht sein
immerhin gehört also man kann weder herr
kemmerich zu bieten dass er kandidiert
noch kann man partei die vorschreiben
wen sie wählen
man kann das alles nicht gut finden aber
man kann jetzt nicht sagen dass das
irgendwie ich demokratisch sei dank
haben wir noch mal eine weitere stimme
wie sich politiker so einspannen lassen
das ist für mich vor allen dingen nicht
nachvollziehbar aber das wird sich sein
ob sich da jetzt wirklich etwas ändert
ob die leute auf die barrikaden gehen
die die wähler weiß man nicht mehr
hoffen war die zuschauerin hätte es für
möglich dass die menschen auf die
barrikaden gehen
also ich vor fünf jahren als bodo
ramelow das erste mal zumindest
präsident gewählt wurde und auch bevor
und und grüne koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart hatte gab es auch
demonstrationen in erfurt und man hat
auch versucht den anfangszeiten auf die
barrikaden zu gehen
ich halte es für legitim dass es solche
meinungsäußerungen gibt dass es proteste
gibt aber ja das eine sind die proteste
das andere sind die demokratischen
prozesse die bei der landtagswahl und
einem dank stattfanden
eine weitere zuschauer frage haben wir
noch eine absolute farce eine lachnummer
ob wunde eines lachen im hals stecken
geblieben
daher käme recht geht den dritten
wahlgang lässt sich wählen und nimmt
diese wahl auch noch an abonniert muss
man eigentlich sein um nicht zu wissen
dass das wie klopapier ist voll schöner
ist dass diese wahl überhaupt keine
chance hat durchzugehen
das land schreibt es müssen die vorher
wissen und da frage ich mich wo sind die
landeschefs wurden die parteichefs oder
chefinnen um da von vornherein einhalt
zu gebieten wie konnte so etwas
überhaupt durchgehen so was hat man sich
eigentlich in den vergangen jahrzehnten
oft gefragt wie konnte so etwas
passieren und ist es einfach passiert ja
es ist ja kein wunschkonzert in diesem
land freunde der nacht fdp ich habe auch
ein buch geschrieben 1000 seiten freuden
und leiden mit der fdp die leiden
beginnen seite 4 und das hat sich heute
eindrucksvoll bewiesen
obwohl es ja nicht nur die fdp alleine
ist es sind ja übergreifend alle
parteien die sich da aus dem fenster
geschmissen haben und das auch nicht nur
heute
ja ich möchte kleines beispiel nennen
ich war vielleicht ein bisschen aus
heute wird jemand gewählt von einer
partei die kein mensch möchte vor allem
der gewählte sagt ich nehme eure stimme
aber nicht eure meinung das ist
halbherzig das ist lächerlich das ist
gar nichts deswegen rücktritt so weit
sind wir glaube ich alle miteinander
gehen ein stückchen weiter in der
gleichen art und güte
september letzten jahres hassprediger
us-rapper demonstration berlin
was sagt ihr bei der regierung greift
oft auftreten und erst kommt ja danke
schön
die bild und auch anderen sagen sollte
wisst nicht was da gerade abgeht was
passiert roger kontert schadens bremse
was haben wir getan
ihr dürft nicht auftreten oder mutter gm
ein stückchen weiter ins schloss
steinmeier herzlichen glückwunsch
telegramm nach teheran
genau so beschreibt die mal heute auch
ohne zu denken
die erde versenken um den anderen dass
ich gar nicht weiter reden
nächster schritt hier semperoper damit
in den norden nach verliehen
ja und erst als alle am start
ein sind und die leute halt absagen in
reih und glied dann wird dieses diese
mit anhieb erkannt und genauso kann man
jetzt hier die lanze brechen nach heute
gewählt worden
oh gott was haben wir getan ja alles
geht von vorne los das kann es aber
nicht sein
ja klar können jetzt kollege fdp
lämmerspiel noch demokratisch gewählt
worden ist dass jetzt durch ich bin ja
mal gespannt aber das wirklich wagt kann
aber gar nicht weil damit von oben bis
sicherheit weggepfiffen werden es gibt
eigentlich in diesem land nur eine
meinung und das ist die richtige und es
ist diese dieser tag in einem satz war
einfach für die demokratie und für das
land scheiße
danke fdp aber auch dank an den rest der
politik herzlich pinker der darin sehr
emotionalen längeren vortrag gehört über
ein gewissen frust dass vielleicht der
politik manchmal das gefühl für die
menschen
total verloren geht und endete damit ein
schlechter tag für die demokratie sehen
sie das auch so die wahl in thüringen
gestern als schlechter tag für
demokratie also das ist ja immer
schwierig wenn demokratisch über ein
schlechter tag für die demokratie ich
glaube dann müssen wir schauen was
rauskommt
wie regiert wird was die inhalte sind
bodo ramelow hat auch die letzten jahre
regiert mit der stimme eines
abgeordneten daten mit der über die asb
im landtag kam und das hat man der
politik aber auch nicht angemerkt also
insofern würde ich jetzt nicht jetzt
schulte stab brechen wollen über das was
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
passiert